this is the videos from the ambassador's
we've decided that emails are pretty
cool but videos take less time and you
guys seem to like that last time I think
the last video that I'd like eight
comments on it
most people were commenting on the fact
that the video was vertical and
horizontal but a copy Commodus yeah okay
so today I'm posted last week I posted
in the Ambassador group about Casey next
step I'd never heard of them recently
yes they called like mail time where
they talk about packages that they got
and we get a lot of packages I'll leave
two or three a day some of you learned
some that are gifts so but I want to
talk about a gifts that we got yesterday
I think so I got it because I company
called eleven James so the back story is
is that I wanted to buy a fancy watch
because my parents have a Rolex that
they bought when they're my age and
they've had forever and so I thought
it'd be cool to also buy back and so I
found the service called eleven James
eleven James comm where you pay between
two hundred and a thousand dollars of
them home life depending on how fancy
but watch you want and they send you a
watch online and I got my first one
yesterday and we don't have to pay for
it but normally it would be about
Twitter box okay maybe 150 I don't know
but we got this package so it came in
kind of a weak box but I guess it makes
sense because they're shipping like a
$50,000 watch and you don't want like it
to be paraded so it kind of it's a
pretty lame looking package and then it
came with a pair of socks which was
pretty cool
Aysen every we had already written about
them in the past and then a card that
said when we owe the watch back this one
is owed back on eleven to
interesting and then some more from
asymmetric and here's the box it came in
not the prettiest box no none at all
and then inside the box was like like
this what so here it is and it so
there's your packaging kind of wack I
think not that good and here's the watch
unfortunately this is not their fault I
gave them the wrong wrist size so this
doesn't fit me wrong but it might fit
Jackie so let's here I'll take you can
try to be good you can put the watch on
let's see what it looks like
do you even know about it
what so you have it on the runway so
what's this what's this call let's watch
can we tell
okay don't list it on the box so so what
do we think do you see well Jackie do
you feel fancier fancy ah it's really
heavy right yeah it is really heavy so
there let's sit back and let's well all
that people know we think that this
watch is any good or not I am able to
put it around my wrist without clasping
it so I could feel the weight and in my
opinion like this is so inconvenient
it's it is probably our horses weighs
maybe a whole pound it is pretty heavy
maybe entire pound it's definitely hard
so it's a bit I think that type of watch
you would only know it's fancy if you're
into that brand it's not like a you know
everyone knows roll out so you see that
name you don't make looking those fancy
that brand I'm not a watch guy so I
never even heard of it but a lot of
watch people have heard of it but it's
so heavy like you would never did it fit
your wrist no it was a little tired
snacks circulation - is both small
resident what happened - a little bit
typically works as big like you print
out this like strip of paper and then
you wrap the paper around your wrist and
it's like a tape measurer and you know
what size it is I actually when the
woman reached out to me I just like pull
marrows like seven inches was my wrist I
thought that was right it because I I
didn't measure it correctly so this is
totally not their fault and they're
sending me more links for it so it fits
but even if they do some more lace this
is so not convenient to type in and it
looks pretty cool but I don't know if
the coolness is worth it what do you
think I mean you know the swag factor is
pretty high on this though you know but
it's not like gold it's over it's true
it's it's older it's hard to miss it
though on your wrist
yeah functionality-wise
it's gonna be doing you any favors so
overall though I actually am pumped with
the service I don't like this watch but
I've seen celebrities wear it and I
would have been tempted to if I want to
spend money to buy it so I'm pumped that
I got to try it out so I think the
service is awesome and interestingly the
best thing with the service is the
business model which I don't know that
you said they set up you said otherwise
but George John was saying was that he
thinks that the this company gives the
watches 2:11 James and a love it James
sends it out in profits from that and
they don't actually have to pay for the
watch because they're doing like PR
that's interesting and so now like if
someone is signed up to the service and
they get like three or four different
watches that they normally would never
have bought maybe they'll try it on
they'll really like it and they'll be
able to go buy it or they'll tell the
people about it so yeah we also saw that
they had a program where if you have a
really expensive watch you're willing to
rent it out to other people if you do
that they're willing to discount give
you a discount on the watches that you
rent properly yeah interesting so if you
have several watches you could probably
just rent a bunch of they're watching
this for free illegal it understeers
that's interesting that's me sweetie
but overall happy with the service not
happy with this watch still not
convinced that having a fancy watch is
worth it other than in my case in many
people's case be like owning something
that like that's an integer that your
family owned you know a sentimental
value that that definitely be worth it
but there's a practicality as it that I
can I do that I don't I don't see it but
I still might buy I wonder
we'll see you made free baller baller
but I don't know if it's worth it yeah
yeah okay okay we'll keep we'll keep
this one short when we have five minutes
705 705 okay we'll keep this short
let us know in the comments what you
think of these types of videos maybe
we'll keep doing on them we'll show you
more
stuff but this is what we were doing
today we're reviewing eleven James and
the service that we get sent to us
thanks ambassadors peace